White House press secretary Sean Spicer
has a tough job he's got to go out into
the White House press briefing room day
after day and lie and distract to cover
Donald Trump's lies and distortions and
policy disasters and sometimes he has to
face questions that can be tough tough
questions to answer this week he went
totally off the rails when he was asked
by a reporter to explain when can we
trust President Trump and when can't we
and the context was before Trump was an
was in in the White House when there
would be jobs numbers that came out
Trump would say the numbers are fake and
phony after Trump is in the White House
those are great numbers fantastic
numbers the best numbers same thing
applies to data from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics as well as the Congressional
Budget Office on other matters so NBC
News's Peter Alexander asked this
completely reasonable question and every
single time Sean Spicer tries to
distract or answer a different question
take a look we can trust it if he's not
joking of course I mean but in that case
hold on but but no no you're asking hold
on okay no no but you're appointed if
he's happy he every time that he speaks
with order but he did he speaks he's
that he's being his president United
States he does believe it Thank You
Julie yeah we have another clip where
Sean Spicer comments further and again
he just cannot answer the simple
question if and when can Trump be
trusted when should Americans trust the
president should they trust the
president is it phonier real when he
says that President Obama was
wiretapping well again let's get back I
think there's two things that are
important about what he said I think
recognizing that it's the Oban he
doesn't really think that President
Obama went up and tapped his phone
personally I think West's when can we
trust the president what he said you
asked a question about CBO and now
you're and now you're conflating it the
question the president no question is
wiretapping first okay go me when I'm
CBO said the question in simple terms is
when he says something is reat when he
says something can we trust that it's
real or should we assume there's phone
will be suggested it's real how could we
believe that it's real when you just
told us that it was phony thing but I
did not tell you that okay Peter let me
answer the question you're not let me
sir the bottom line is the percentage of
people are unemployed varies widely by
who you're asking and the way you do the
analysis of who's actually in the
workforce yes or no
our CBO numbers legitimate or not that's
not my determination to make I'm telling
as I mention no no I Palli it depends
there certain a lot of things that seem
whole not Halle you guys have like an
NBC thing let me let me answer the
question it's I think when you look at
the whatever that number is whether it's
Buzzard projections or whatever I think
there's a track record that goes along a
lot of times with whether or not the
projections in certain areas whether
it's unemployment budgetary numbers
whatever are what the track record
because none of these are answers to the
question and the answer to this totally
reasonable question is that you can
almost never trust Trump if you think
Pat about all the different issues that
Donald Trump has commented on from the
time that his campaign began through
today is there one general area where
Trump has always been upfront honest and
accurate rather than deceptive I can't
think
not with jobs not with foreign policy I
can't think of a single area where we
can say hey listen on this air in this
area on this topic you can trust Trump
especially because if something goes
wrong for him he can just backtrack and
say that he was joking all along even
though there may have been no indication
of that so for example when he invited
Russia it's a search for Hillary
Clinton's missing 30,000 emails Oh such
a few later walked that back as a joke
clearly wasn't at the time let me point
out something else that Sean Spicer does
did you notice when he was asked whether
it was either the CBO or the BLS that
that I think is Hallie Jackson from NBC
said there can the CBO numbers be
trusted he said that's not his call to
make
Spicer does this brilliant thing of sort
of turning a switch on or off for
whether he is or isn't a proxy for the
president depending on the question
he's the press secretary his job is to
speak for the President and communicate
what the President believes the question
about whether the be CBO numbers are
fake
real should be interpreted as is it the
position of this administration that the
CBO numbers are fake or real Spicer says
it's not my call to make whether the
numbers can be trusted which is a way to
avoid answering the question by claiming
he doesn't speak for the president the
question is what is the position of the
administration you represent on the CBO
numbers and he does this where he will
just say hey listen I don't know III
that's not my job I mean they kind of
have to because if they don't stay
consistent that way they can disagree
with the numbers when it works against
their narrative of course I agree with
them when they do I have this fantasy
that Spicer will crack during one of
these hearings and quit on the spot and
say he just can't do it anymore and
it'll become one of the best viral
videos a sort of ragequit video that
will be it will meme fi Spicer in
political history forever I don't know
if that's a reasonable thing to wait
around for I'm not holding my breath but
I'm hoping it happens we've seen it
happen with news anchors live on TV yeah
I mean he would get a job somewhere else
real quick if he did that oh absolutely
he could do propaganda for any number of
organizations discuss this with us on
reddit we have a reddit discussion forum
you can access it by going to david
pakman.com slash our EDD i.t we'll be
back after this
Gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s